it's certainly a a significant plan um
but it's a pair back plan from the one
that was first proposed so
you know the government obviously is
working hard to you know sort of boost
this but
um
the truth of the matter is although
there are significant benefits for
manchester in this plan and i readily
acknowledge those benefits
the test our residents will apply is
connectivity across the north because
that's the biggest problem when it comes
to rail and on that test this plan falls
quite some way short of what we've been
promised it's not the new line that
we've been promised in three
conservative manifestos
but just from manchester's perspective
doesn't that look a bit i don't know
maybe ungrateful is the wrong word but i
mean you know the the hs2 that fast line
is still connecting manchester
true uh not in the way we want but yes
it is but the truth of the matter as i
say is the east west connectivity is the
most important
and if bradford is out on a limb and
leeds doesn't have the right level of
connectivity with manchester that that
affects us as well because you know the
north of england is if you like
modern geography and we all need to be
connected and it's not just about
manchester's connections uh to to london
so you know this is um a plan that goes
some way to addressing our needs but not
all of the way when it comes to the
north of england east west it's a second
class plan and i don't believe you level
up the country on on second second best
okay but let's um look at the facts here
i mean according according to the
government so the the original plan from
manchester to leeds was to cut the
journey time to 29 and a half minutes
under the the current proposals then
what they are actually going to do it's
33 minutes it's not much of a difference
and of course a saving of 18 billion
pounds
well yes i my team say if this
plan of a partner line and an upgrade on
the victorian infrastructure is done
properly it could deliver those journey
times well what that won't tell you
derma if you just look at that
is that it won't give you as much
capacity as a new line so you can have
many more train paths per hour if you
have a new line but i would just say to
you
take that piece of sort of spin if you
like from the government what do you
make of that if you live in bradford
because you're cut out completely you're
gonna have to go to leeds first before
you can get on that uh that that new
line so
you know this isn't what we were what we
were promised and you know as we sit
here uh
we know that london is about to get a
brand new east-west uh line tunneled
under the capital now we don't begrudge
the capital because obviously it needs
um
the transport investment befitting of
its of its status as a global city
however why don't we get the same you
know you used the word before why should
we always have to be grateful for what
we are given that's how the north of
england has always been treated when it
comes to transport we are second-class
citizens when it comes to transport and
if i were to sit here today and say to
you oh well it's it's second class but
we're just gonna have to accept it as
good enough i would be condemning my
great-grandchildren and beyond and
everyone else is here in the north
for them to live as second-class
citizens when it comes to transport and
you know we're fed up of that we're not
prepared to accept it and it's why we
will still hold out for that new line
that we were promised by three
conservative manifestos
i'm interested in what you said there
about it's not necessarily about the
speed given the the minor differences
there are between uh what will happen
and what was originally proposed between
manchester and leeds but it's about the
capacity now on that issue of capacity
given what we've just been through and
all this talk about working from home
and changed working patterns and giving
people flexibility these are only
forecasts aren't they about demand for
future capacity in decades to come they
might actually be lower you might not
need this bigger capacity
possibly
but
you know if you look at the reality of
traveling around the north of england
today if you look at the m62 today it is
just shocker block all the way from uh
manchester the north of manchester to
the m60 all the way across the penins
there's just a huge volume of of road
traffic there if you then travel on our
trains you will see huge numbers of
people it's very difficult to get a seat
so
even if we're not going to have the same
numbers of people using public transport
which i think for us we probably are but
even if we weren't we still need a
massive increase in east-west transport
capacity across the pennines and across
across the north
so are you uniting with uh other leaders
political community
business across the north to to fight
this whatever party they may come from
yeah it's not a case of fight it all
because as i said there are some
benefits here so i'm not coming on to
sort of you know
play politics and just say oh it's all
awful it's not there are some good
things in this plan but it falls short
on that critical thing of a new line uh
via bradford and uh into leeds
and it's that issue that i think could
be changed and so together with other
northern leaders some 25 of us have
written to the prime minister and what
we've said is let's have a free vote on
this plan before it goes any further you
may remember hearing him dermot another
conservative saying that the
conservatives were loaned
votes at the last general election so
what i would say to that is let those
mps elected on those loaned votes to
have a free vote on these plans
and then a judgment can be made about
whether or not these are the right plans
for the north of england and the reason
i say free vote is take party politics
out of it
you know this these are decisions that
will affect generations of people
in the north of england generations to
come this will affect life here for
hundreds of years we've got to take the
right decision short term decisions to
chop a few billions out here or there
i think needs to be set against the long
term uh opportunities of the north this
new line i'm told costs only four
billion pounds more than the line that
they've settled on you know really is it
really worth that saving to chop
bradford completely out of this honestly
i just don't think it is and i
my view is a majority of mps if they
were able to come to an independent
decision on this would probably agree
and say yes reinstallate that new line
and if that was put back in i think this
plan would be a lot more palatable to a
lot more people
in the north so in the party politics of
this
if this government is peeing off the red
wall seats that it took from labor in
the last election i mean just in naked
political terms that can't be a bad
thing in terms of your analysis
that isn't you know what this is about
for me and i and to show your viewers
that it's not all about party politics
the government i was in didn't do enough
for the north when it comes to transport
so this is a failure on all sides all
political parties
you know i would rather leveling up
worked i'd rather it did what the
government said uh it should do but you
don't level up with a second bl best
plan you know we needed a premier league
plan and we've got a championship plan
here and and that isn't going to be good
enough for us leveling up will require
you to put the best plan forward and
because london is getting that new
east-west line next year i think
actually if this plan goes ahead the gap
will get bigger the gap in terms of
transport connectivity between north and
south will only get only get bigger so
i'd rather they did the right thing
because sometimes the right thing and
making a real difference for our
residents is more important than
you know political gains and and one
side being up on one side being down